une production du studio sf salut tout
le monde
aujourd'hui le podcast est commandité
par ce tram ce tram ces dépouilles en
acier inoxydable ça veut dire que au
lieu de prendre appareils en plastique
lâcheté cassera voir dans l'océan
qu'as-tu des poissons puis à prendre et
ntv composée d'appareils tu l'achètes
une fois plus petit que j'utilise toute
ta vie d'enfant nicole vont mettre des
balises image de parent ici puis ici
lorsqu'ils goûtent un audio on s'imagine
des belles portes en acier de toutes les
couleurs sont vraiment magnifiques sont
faciles à traîner c'est vraiment super
sympa avec toi puis un poteau où tu veux
te prends ta pas réutilisable alors il
est plusieurs couleurs plusieurs modèles
anneaux des plus grosses pour 10 me fier
d avoir comme ceux des plus petites
c'est facile à nettoyer il ya des
petites pochettes gens avec ça peut
traîner ce drame fait aussi d'autres
produits comme des ustensiles et on a un
code promo code promo sans filtre vous
allez avoir 15 % de rabais sur votre
commande de paye et d'autres produits
strahm l'en remercie beaucoup à ce tram
et bombe à castres
[Musique]
notamment ces marques étaient venus chez
nous on casse à paris on n'est quand
même pas le microsillon peuple
c'était particulièrement zen est
vraiment aimé ce pauvre il était comme
ce matin mais tellement évolué qui
revient dès que c'était vraiment un bon
pas de casse avec moi elle montre que le
monde et dans un format pas de sa
première fois qu'il parlait aussi
longtemps quelque chose je pense que le
monde ont vraiment qu'en fait ok non
c'est vraiment post que ce qu'on a
entendu quelqu'un qui nous parlait de sa
business
comment il monte sa frappe ces quartiers
non c'est vraiment pas mais moi quand
j'ai rencontré je vais j'avais c'était
perception lui je pensais que c'était un
douchebag cliquer je voulais pas sortir
avec lui je me suis juste fier à
l'apparence
je suis quelqu'un comme qui aiment lire
j'aime aller au musée à faire plus comme
ce qu'il me rejoigne et puis là je
découvre cam s'est dit que la carrière
comme ça l'est toujours été comme ça
s'intéressent à ma femme qui est qui qui
va pas bien surtout au début de sa
carrière son côté le ski était plus
jeune et des hits et son stéréo type le
mans series mais en vieillissant inquiet
comme des coureurs at on déjà en tournée
je yes i'm here 6 4 venus de venir nous
jaser ça serait pas de caste
qu'est ce que c'est pourquoi il y avait
un panier complet de
la sellerie ya chez nous un panier
d'épicerie l'espace carat comme ne va
rien changer du tout doux c'est sûr
parce que j'avais pu place dans le frigo
facture qu'est ce que je vais faire avec
tous et céleri mais quand je dis quelque
chose à marcq exécute un gerard piqué je
fasse attention à ce que je dis c'est
impossible et je pense qu'on a du jus
pourrait m'aider comme médium c'est un
gars qui est dit qu'il est plein de
bienfaits à pied on s'est dit pourquoi
pas eh ouais 810 sérieusement son
instinct g s'est décéléré le poids du
céleri pont on s'est dit c'est juste
drôle on va essayer si on sent bien
pourrait qu'en bois comme un verre de
jus de céleri le matin c'est soit que tu
sais tu as un smoothie de céleri ou
angie fait qu'on extrait tout la pulpe
pour ouvrir la culture avait comme j'ai
appris à prendre sous peu
c'est juste drôle ça fait des sensations
kaka serait fausse et créative qui les
gens qui ont fait il est de série
mais c'est sûr que ça peut pas être
mauvais de prendre il je ne veux pas que
ce n'est pas tant de chemin dans des
selleries sûrement c'est un des seuls
allemands qui est comme neutre like anti
calories puis quand tu le manges lieu au
sein de ton énergie à masquer vient
d'annuler les quatre galeries pas
répondre
on s'en inquiète pas que c'est juste je
pourrai manger domaine des selleries
sens
il y avait les cyclistes du tour de
france fond c'était commune une histoire
slash mais peut-être que c'est vrai
peut-être que non mais je m'entends dire
qu'il faisait en camp d'entraînement qui
est vraiment leur objectif c'était m au
poids au poids qui veulent être parce
que tu es là dans une affaire comme ça
sur des épreuves pas possible que le
tour de france était à 1 kg de plus ça
fait vraiment une différence quand c'est
le temps de monter une côte
puis il faisait des soupes zéro calorie
fait que dans le fond pas déçu qu'à des
galeries négatif et une enfance et le
temps de manger ta soupe tu perds des
calories dans un bouillon de rien c'est
ce genre de l'eau chaude avec un petit
peu de saveur de focales cinq livres en
plus à la cour
oui c'est vraiment plus l'ofac mais je
l'avais fait qu'un jeune âge et je m'en
suis jamais rendu compte vraiment le tir
je m'en rendais compte qu'en mettant
fallait face des distances plus longues
que ce que je t'ai habitude fort mais
quand j'ai commencé à courir le si mon
poids et j'ai quand même capable de
contrôler mon poids c'est assez
facilement le titre capable de passer de
béton 185 475 en une semaine et
indépendant qu'est ce que je mange des
pistes du couple et curb situé face ils
le perdent dans la tension dr
puis je le remarque le vraiment vraiment
vraiment beaucoup
en course à pied car anne hengy plus ou
moins ça fait longtemps que j'ai pas
nager quand ça veut pas ça veut dire
mais je réalise à quel point c'était un
défi si j'ai jamais mangé de ma vie le
groupe s'il faut que choisir je me
faisais que je me relaxe dans l'eau puis
je pourrais au début le che et 50 moins
que j'arrivais sur la psyché comme pays
voyons quelles postures et jamey carroll
de plus en plus comme la semaine passée
j'ai un break rouge capable de respirer
des deux côtés ça change la gagne
même avant je me tournais du côté gauche
avalé une gorgée à chaque fois c'est
comme les voyons qu'est ce que je fais
de pau correct et je me fais comme coach
et fax ou ça m'a vraiment aidé pour pas
prendre de mauvais plis pileux la
nouvelle games a fait quatre semaines
que je fais toutes les disciplines
sulfate charge fait du vélo chez la
course chez de la nage
le jeune charlie mix oui ici c'est
spécial le pauvre et je pensais pas que
mon corps est allé leur centre il
après comme une heure de vélo en barque
ils sont intactes il a les jambes les
hanches comme mon dieu mon dieu sait
comme cana de la menace ouais quand
christiane mais c'est vraiment un beau
défi parce qu'elle est au niveau sportif
j'avais comme j'avais pas fais le tour
le on s'entend il ya plein d'autres
défis à accomplir mais j'ai l'impression
que dans la muscu
je me sentais y aller au gym j'aimais ce
mais j'avais fait des compétitions de
fitness je me suis rendu au niveau
national en bikini ai compris qu il s
attendait photos disponibles avec mon
esprit tanet une pelouse du mythique
mais londres est inquiet c'est vraiment
un déficit de performance pipeau de
déchets y pointe taxe est vraiment
particulier c'est qui c'est quoi la
différence majeure mais tant que tu vois
dans ces deux c2 façon de s'entraîner
lot émettant de d'avoir parce que encore
le triathlon 12 de ses postes selon
toutes les normes de beauté c'est pas un
corps des athlètes mais je veux dire
aussi si tu deviens super chétif du haut
du corps pitié mais tant que tu fais
quoi maintenant que tu vois comme comme
mindset quand tu arrives dans la salle
d'entraînement parce que c'est plus d'or
aussi le triathlon mais des fois
j'allais deux fois au jam et vous gérez
cessé de s'améliorer pour un temps ou
pour une performance d'endiguer les
fitness était jugé par un jeu c'est pas
un temps en fait c'est ça dépend de la
journée ce le jure je t'aime la face et
c'est ce qu'ils recherchent prime à la
fin de match
de fitness et tout les jours je n'ai
comme un peu plus de masse musculaire un
peu plus des pôles pour gmail code
je commençais à me trouver pour jack
city c'est ben correct qui se trouve
près c'est les méchants mais mais put à
la fin puis même pourcentage de gras
très bon ben c'est pas saint germain
peut entrer atlan je pense que je peux
garder un pourcentage quand même assez
sain button ont grossi aussi une source
d'énergie
c'est quoi le faisait à la nage boostés
quoi veut le croire la brasse les
papillons ou faisait des tours mixtes à
bab since i sava de la plus courte
distance et 50 m ok puis la plus longue
c'est 1500 m c'est vraiment différent
mais souvent très spécialisés à quelques
quelques courses lequel il s'était fait
que plus d'argent qu'ils ont faim qui
voile fait aucun argent qui veulent
banda dans tous les sens ça c'est
quelque chose je peux soit enlevé par
les sur le podcast le mais à chaque fois
que j'y repense a atteint en 2008 bien
que dernier huit médailles d'or aux jeux
olympiques
à chaque fois que je pense que tout le
temps quelque chose qui m'apparaît puis
mettons tout 10 a aucun sens qu et puis
je comprends que tu trouves ça n'a aucun
sens mais si tu comprenais l'étendue de
ce que réalise et comme comme étant nous
on le comprend parce qu'on le fait le
yoyo qui a gagné le 100 m papillon puis
a gagné le 400 m 4 nages
ça pourrait pas parler même cinquante
mille cinq cents s'arrête durant l'été
ça pourrait pas être plus loin c'était
ça pourrait sciemment pour être plus
loin c'est comme si c'est comme si je
fais de l'athlétisme plus tu gagnes 100
m course à pied mais tu gagnes aussi de
quoi il parle
m et c'est capoter le tchèque mais
effectivement à bord lui beaucoup de
monde qu'il y avait eu un truc
spécifiques et vous étiez bon ok moi ça
va changer beaucoup
j'ai conçu en carrière en étant même ma
carrière qu'un connecté au secondaire
j'étais vraiment plus je prenais pas
beaucoup de masse musculaire comme selon
l'ars tout mon secondaire même segev
connais pas beaucoup de masse musculaire
fait que tu aies m'entraîner beaucoup
pipeau gonflé qui est fait que je
faisais tiers des distances plus longues
je commençais 4 100 m 200 m
c'est dans ce coin le plus quand
j'arrivais à l'université pour une
raison que j'ignore complètement j'ai
commencé à être prendre de la masse le
genre quickly fait que je fais si
j'allais en muscu pelouse de cannes qui
ce genre avant chaque course et à s'en
sont allés y pleut maintenant écrit je
rendais à 185 puis jorge chicote le mais
je peux plus faire un 400 m en 6
transitionner par les 50 1 kg et 50
crawl papillon 50 dos d'écran l'écran
les papillons surtout on revient sur sa
bouche et on voyait dans la piscine ça
c'est quand vous étiez 1 1 pp cela vous
êtes rencontrés c'était très drôle parce
que mon team très musculaire fac ça il
n'y avait aucune technique d'un ange
mais il y aller vite parce qu'ils
étaient forts
c'est éclabousse est tellement partout
entre il faisait du papillon 15 de
calais mais c'est pas fluide ya longet
pas le brusquer
c'est que c'est vraiment technique tpiy
c'était le pognon et steve des câbles
d'énergie plus longtemps mais c'est pour
ça devienne naturel puis normal de
norges il faut nager beaucoup de nous on
angèle
j'ai tellement beaucoup le tir
secondaire on était en avait eu huit
entraînements en piscine par semaine
c'est en plus de l'alcool c'est tout ça
en plus de la muscu puis des
entraînements de souvent 5 6000 mètres
les deux avec des deux des bondieuseries
mais je les respecte et des fois tu as
l'impression de juste nord géorgie petit
voyons si on fait une large place aux
salariés mais j'ai l'impression que vu
que c'était un environnement qui est peu
au milieu instable c'est un milieu qui
n'est pas naturel pour lui mais je sais
on vit pas dans l'oubli sous la tente de
devenir à l'aise dans l'eau foot reçoit
beaucoup dans l'eau le cinoche noces
loges pour que notre état devienne comme
marcher c'est un faux messi seul
problème en plus parce que mettons
plutôt à ma carrière quand qu'il y avait
une question de dates en physiquement en
forme et on faire du cardio la natation
il n'était plus assez pour moi
maintenant on insisté rendu exactement
tellement naturel que je te regarde de
monter mes pulsations dans une piscine
j'ai remis les muses devenait gonfle et
puis je t'ai physiquement musculairement
plus capable d'avancer mais j'avais les
pulsations ça en 30 puis salle c'est mon
épaule c'est fait pour faire mon
quartier haut pour essayer de contrôler
mon pour fallait que j'aille sur tapis
roulant pif alors je vais le faire ces
quatre courses les 7 juin le 7 juin ou à
blainville
c'est quoi la distance et sur un sprint
pour commencer ça va bien je fais une
longue un olympique c'est 750 m c'est
pourtant que comme un échec que jamais
vraiment danger si je suis incapable
il reste quatre mois mon entraînement
je sais que je vais être capable
adrénaline oh pardon mais c'est quand
même un challenge foulées j'ai appris
que sûrement que ça va pas
il va falloir que je serais un accès ils
nagent avec d'autres gens ici c'est
quand même elle s'appelle viola la marge
garantie pour savoir des coups de coude
[Musique]
de vélo ça va pour rien vélo et 20 kg de
vélo ça au moins c'est ce qu'on aimait
gros max anarchy lente et apprécié à 1 5
km de course etc soucier tabou je pense
juste des noms gib a été inférieur
j'espère que je vais pas comme sortie de
la piscine après les gens mais on peut
toujours se profile une remontée oui
mais j'imagine que je serai pas la
meilleure donc fabriqué non plus moi
j'avais de plus de quatre ans car les
plus jeunes a fait de la natation parce
que j'ai vraiment fait mon grand frère
beaucoup triathlon qui était comme
d'ailleurs au québec puis mots j'en
faisais un peu le tir les tétées
qu'acheter au de natation puis moi
c'était complètement les verse l'état y
est sorti premier de la piscine chance
premier lot d'après seul vélo je me suis
d'avis la course au 6 mai
et honnêtement dans la douleur que j'ai
ressentie mais un triathlon la course
afin le rien de plus tous les russes
mais andre geim c est comme j'aime
j'aime pas l'entraînement jusqu'à temps
que ça devienne toute chance pour ceux
qui pensent ce qu'ils imaginent mal mais
maintenant qu'on est le même on m6
pousser jusqu'à temps que ça fasse
vraiment mal pied concentré dans le sous
sol en se trompant nous autres pour été
le monde je me sens très une pub
également mais qui devrait occuper un
sac à main sans fauqué c'est très
business mais en même temps c'est
correct parce qu'elles ont été pierre t
es tu peux pas faire qu'à priori sens et
jusqu'aux humains fait grimer le côté un
peu plus social de côté ces relations
étaient à bord notre couple géant qui
vieillit très faux cul sur la job et
c'est trés le texte des x games and ton
art art l'art de quoi prochainement
effet vraiment of electric toi il te
faut un mois pour réaliser les
triathlons fait l'entraînement plaît je
veux partir de mon entreprise que ma
carrière je veux donner un bon un peu
comme marque et on veut les r d enfants
pardon comme un petit boost carrière
parce qu'on veut être des parents
présents le live on serait au départ un
prix donné un petit ticket la carrière
ça roule un peu tout seul médecin qui
avait des délégués s'occuper de vraiment
y engage beaucoup de jeunes et de femmes
c'est comme la gestion humaine aussi ah
oui ça notre déficit moi je parle mon
entreprise mais j'ai comme un bon mental
mais très bon désiste moi je suis j'irai
cache pas bonne en business parce que je
comme ultra humainement même temps c'est
une autre façon de voir les choses
ça amène
c'est sûr qu'il faut il faut que tu
trouve quelque chose de complémentaire
j'imagine parce que moi souvent souvent
je crois que les gens sont
fondamentalement bien intentionnés qui
des fois faut que je me fasse dire amen
la tête en train de littéralement te
faire piler dessus c'est ça c'est ce
exact puisque amener ça devient s'étoffe
à gérer et c'est d'essayer de couper
l'émotionnel tpiy mais toi tu entends
des fois le du monde qui met on te
regarde un film brio deux personnes qui
se battent stable et 10 km c'est juste
la business du genre tout juste la
business team et se comprendre ce site
off ans actuellement de dire c'est pas
moi personnellement que tu attaques non
des bonnes valeurs qui s'ébattent
backstab s'est dit si l'essm est dans
les rôles la personne que je me dis
toutes les personnes qui backstab qui
font des mouvements corps et que c'est
juste des gens qui souffrent c'est fake
montrait g pardon pour un peu yoga mais
c'est ce qui arrive quelque chose ou
même en auto qui est quelqu'un fume fuck
you est beau gentil avec moi dans mon
quotidien je comme l'envoi de lamotte et
6eme ce genre je te pardonne c'est comme
même sa personne les ressemblances un
peu moins chaud comme à bienne avait dit
je me couche d'or bien pied mais il
n'est pas blessé personne oui c'est de
vivre ce sont ces principes là c'est sûr
que oui quand une personne présentait
des fois et des gens abuse de toi mais
je sais pas j'ai mieux géré que c'est le
carnot ça va me revenir puis je reste
positive à tracer non mais c'est clair
cette personne qui copie je t'envoie
chiffres sur la goutte est probablement
moins heureux au quotidien que toile à
ce que cette journée une hypothèse ne
m'étais jamais envoyé chez quelqu'un ou
voilà je suis vraiment pas intéressé en
fait j'ai très peu
comme chaque année avec quelqu'un
jusqu'à moi je vois pas vraiment
l'intérêt de pierre-paul pour rien et
mes défauts qui marche mieux à vous
hisser qu'est ce mois ci l'accord bino
au cap on avait une vidéo piste -comme
c'est quoi ton pire défaut c'est vrai
que comme moi qu'à une station quelque
chose qui me fait pendant la foire japon
est confronté ou que mme affirmé que
juste mais fermé le sas à blaise les
parce que s'ils agissent peau et savent
pas qu est ce que dans ta tête je vais
juste me faire nos petites fuites c'est
particulier mais comme je pense que
j'aime peut se faire des agressions pied
je trouve ça sert à rien c'est la
personne qui fait des agressions c'est
elle qui blessent au final c'est sévère
j'en sais quelque et la douleur la whey
mais oui c'est ça c'est justement faire
un coup chez quelqu'un faire mentir à
quelqu'un si toi aussi tu quittes rempli
de crottes l'ausim drame en haïti mais
c'est sans mieux quand et transparente
cantona est aussi chaud c'est un beau
principe encore possible ben oui ces
jours ci j'ai commencé à bouger
commencer ces jours-ci j'ai des moments
où est ce que comme je deviens justement
vraiment moins patients qui vit plus
comme justement l'été quelqu'un qui me
coupe dans charles souvent ça me fait ch
locale puis commun qui est humaine mais
des fois ça me pompe que j'ai commencé à
essayer de comprendre
c'est quand que je réagis comme ce
pourquoi est ce que aujourd'hui la
personne m'a coupé pourquoi ça me fait
autant fichier puis souvent le jeu donne
cet exemple hommes et plein d'autres
affaires qui arrivent dans vie qui me
font chier le thé mais je me dis mais
souvent quand ça me dérange pauvres est
ce parce que cette journée là où cette
semaine là il ya vraiment eu une
accumulation d'affaires qui m'ont amené
là mais d accumulation d'affaires qui
qui m'habite que je pense que je garde
avec moi tu fais que du négatif que je
décide
inconsciemment d'amener avec moi plus
loin dans semaine peu plus loin dans la
journée puis qui finalement font que
s'accumuler
j'ai commencé à me dire la décision de
prendre ce négatif flop et de l'emmener
avec moi c'est moi qui la prends le
train je pourrais laisser les trucs
négatifs qui m'arrive
au moment où ça m'arrive puis pas les
laisser m'affecter plus tard pour éviter
que j'arrive à un trop plein qui fait
que je pète une note à jesse metcalfe on
est chez nous que je pète une note à
google qui me coupe dans charléty puis
messi c'est un travail qui est de la
capacité d'introspection fait le travail
et des jeux comme attendu ils font des
actes comme ceux qui ça finit le new
york post est un grand succès c'est une
réflexion que tu face à jesse je pense
que ça m'a mis à l'aise avec les gens
qu'on aime respect pour ce que tu es
avec tes collègues fait plus fort
regarde moi l'été la profonde
c'est sûr que c'est un travail à ce
travail à faire puis puis dans toutes
les c'est toi tu le fais le camp même si
le yoga pilates est ce que tu me dit oui
je me dit mais pas de façon assidue
non mais si j'ai des périodes de temps
où je me dit ça va bien comme sur un
pont surtout pas manquer justement la
vie vous met de côté mais le yoga c'est
une forme de médiation pour yolande
façon quand même assez régulière ok oui
je mais dit de pas mal souvent je
prédisais que oui ça va changer ma vie
le yoga a été comme un point tournant
dans ma vie qui m'a vraiment aidé dans
plein de situations au pied et au gaz
peut juste faire des pauses et la partie
méditation respiration souci la
respiration ce après quelque chose qui
ait beaucoup de gens pourraient observer
ou comme apprendre des techniques de
respiration puis on peut ce petit musée
grâce à ce fait que j'aime vraiment ce
yoga que j'ai appris en inde
c'est comme une place que ça va prendre
beaucoup plus je prends ça va la changer
mon voyage en inde sont venus jeter
comme un voyage de 2 go with you guys
matin au sort ah ouais tout comme moi
soit je m'entraîne en sachet de muscu je
fais des bikinis fitness puis amman et
qu'il se chicaner puis le terminal young
comme un peu ce qui s'est passé ils ont
pensé oui et non parce que je regardais
les deux puis la première fois où j'ai
comme rentrer dans le yoga sont peu dire
j'ai à l'aide d'une façon un peu plus je
vais perdre du tc comme très laid yoga
cholet quand j'ai su ça va être un bon
hors cac havas complémenter je vais être
folle en chef j'ai réalisé le quai c'est
beaucoup plus que ça
diop stand partie de ma vie où je vais
beaucoup d'anxiété qu'après chaque
séance de yoga
j'ai braillé système en est pas drôle et
maçonnerie mais en même temps les c'est
là que j'ai vu qu'elle yoga c'est
beaucoup plus que juste des postures
beaucoup plus que juste le physique du
pied les grands mâles de yoga dans le
fond ils font les postures de yoga pour
l'alignement mais c'est pour être
immobile pendant les arrêts méditer
pendant des heures fixes et puis
vraiment justes et flexible est qu'il
faut être flexible qui oui ça va moi je
peux très flexible jeu prof de yoga mais
j'peux la plus flexible piges
ça me dérange pas mais je trouve que mes
élèves peuvent realite' parce que je les
sens en même temps que dans la poster en
tout cas profs qui font l'aspect
purement pas rien son dos un comblement
peine ouais c'est ça c'est plus facile
les développeurs puis je m'en viens de
plus en plus flexible mais je peux
ressentir l'étirement comme une personne
dans des mouvements plus de base c'est
vraiment cool moi j'étais tendu un
jardin pas de préjugés métier de 10,4
les gens disent je fais du yoga
je me sens tellement bien je me sens
apaisé plus disait tout le temps moi
mais tu fais l'activité physique of
course que tu te sens mieux dans le sens
que d'aller courir ou quoi que ce soit
après ce temps un sentiment bien être
mais tout est dit qu'il ya vraiment un
haut niveau mettant vraiment
différemment après être allée au jim
d'avoir travaillé qui d'être allé au
yoga même temps - jay kay le travail au
niveau du yoga c'est plus à l'intérieur
puis tandis que la muscu les autres
sports comme est la course annoncé comme
extérieur isis comme l'arche et les
serrures lise d'entretien travailler un
peu plus à l'intérieur de toi et aussi
ces lignes on la respiration et des
mouvements dont le fils quand on fait de
la muscu inspiré planté mais là c'est
vraiment important le tu vois qui est si
tu respires pas dans une posture béton
corps va pas te permettre d'aller plus
loin un pire c'est ce qui choque et body
yoga l'oeil alimentera les chances et
ceux ci les trucs un peu plus douce et
denrées la religion aussi l'un des
disques cd beaux principes pour eux et
pour moi j'ai commencé à une
végétarienne ya deux ans puis ça a été
un beau chiffre tous dans la vie de par
rapport à ne pas blesser un animal un
peu blessé un autre mais ne pas se
blesser soit la région la région paye
aussi un peu indissociables à ton avis
mais on a ici c'est carrément pas cécile
mais la philosophie dans le véhicule est
pareil la philosophie dioguardi comme
quand sur un cours de yoga en inde des
cours des fleuves et fia tous les jours
c'est vraiment
quand même fascinant les trucs qui parle
et puis c'est vraiment beau qu'est ce
qu'on apprend travers ce billet n'est
jamais fait du yoga août
j'ai fait vieux que j'en faisais des
fois le matin jean avec des vidéos
youtube le genre est ce qu'il ya des
gens qui n'étaient yoga puis je voyais
ça justement comme un genre de de bois
meubles quasiment parce que des fois
j'allais au deuxième après où vous juste
un moment de 2,6 au lieu de rêver de
mais aussi pour la flexibilité
tu dis que c'est pas les choux météores
juste devant ces mouvements là je
trouvais que comme l'abs je me sentais
comme des émotions qui sont pris dans
les parties fac inger en général vous
savez les anges très tight déclare ce
qui est en général vous retenir plus vos
émotions
mais je sais pas si c'est vrai pauvre
aimé des postures six tours à expliquer
parce que les gens mon pauvre dame et
les pigeons à l'avant toit aurait plus
un peu beaucoup avant mais entre la
natation c'est comme un siège qui était
bon mais les lakers et voilà les coudes
et hugo reis à dessein pour relever il
souffle les filles sont couchées c est
ce que c'est parce qu'on est moins d
d'émotion prix là dedans je suis pas
fait pour ouvrir en dit long on y croit
pas mais c'est quelque chose que
j'aimerais vraiment essayé c'est la
méditation comme tel c'est parce que je
n'ai jamais fait mais tu sais si c'est
documenté le jeu doit cesser réel les
effets que que la méditation au sud sur
l'esprit sur le corps
raymond même avant de manger ce serait
bon de que tout le monde fasse des
respirations profondes
on est trop stressé et et l'esprit y est
c'est fait c'est omniprésent dans nos
vies ça ne m'empêche c'est comme un
précurseur de malades il juste prendre 4
respiration complète avant de manger ça
ça changerait tout
on a on serait moins blot t on
absorberait mieux les nutriments
c'est fou parce que quand on est stressé
on épand maison et j'ai mangé le rapido
qui avant autre chose personnes au
travail a baissé
on a eu un podcast avec des
nutritionnistes justement pis si une des
recommandations maintenant du tiki de
notre canadien c'est l'étonnement
j'étais vraiment le temple le plaisir de
manger manger avec des gentils fait que
justement j'étais à sandwich et à course
en auto étonnamment un meeting ou quoi
que ce soit si ça arrive sous terre à
terre des méditations les pro mac 1 20
minutes par jour c'est amplement
suffisant et et mettons qu'il lève le
matin qui fait en vingt minutes
ou est-ce que tu replace trafford si ça
doit vraiment mieux commencer à wenling
fort ça va vraiment avoir un impact sur
toute la journée
même le soir tous qu'est ce que tu fais
avant de coucher ça va avoir un toit
parce que c'est exact c'est simple il
faut quelqu'un qui jetait plus jeune que
je gai mais beaucoup le cash game avant
le coucher j'arrive à mon lit puis
j'avais le pire semaine de ma vie parce
que j'avais des flashs de dangereux
qu'elle jouait piste est vraiment de la
merde
puis ce ce concept là qui quand j'étais
plus jeune l'a mené de me suis dit
qu'ils arrêtent de jouer aussi tort que
ce avant d'aller se coucher sa potence
l'éthique que j'ai recommencé grandes
communes notamment avant le sommeil
d'arrêter complètement de faire quoi que
ce soit sur son ordi ou à 9 heures puis
de soi lire ou faire autre chose mais je
n'aimais vraiment mieux mais ce concept
le on dirait que j'ai bac
accor a vendu à l'appliquer à ma vie
adulte lui et il le veut et son ton
téléphone a empêché depuis maintenant
plus qu on a par la marque
oui ça change vraiment tout métier je
passe mon téléphone par contre juste en
train de faire des trucs pour le travail
puis le camp mais elle tend à me coucher
je savoir toutes les affaires du travail
qui tourne dans ma tête à place d'avoir
des images de jeux vidéo les ti le
problème est le même c'est juste la
cause des différentes
sauf que l'oeil exactement c'est en ce
moment je me dis qu'il faut que je
trouve une façon que quand j'arrive dans
l'eee ou quand j'arrive à l'heure de me
coucher avant d'aller coucher en transe
notamment faut que je loge tout ces
fonds il faut que je veux que je pense
complètement réinventé août puis de
turin puis je trouve la façon de faire
je pense à lecture c'est le best la
lecture ça fait que tout est parti de
regarder un écran du patron de penser à
ta job en train de passer ce kit estrie
c'était juste ailleurs puis sa relaxe à
des tempes il s'endort président stars
comme un bébé
regarde rossi mais vous regarderez
l'instant n'a dit shaw d'annoncer en un
peu mais ce qu'est la respiration par et
les narines alterné boucher narine
gauche la droite et expire par la narine
gauche et vice versa ça vient calmer
vraiment le système nerveux central ou
mêmes jeux ça les fera quelques petits
étirements vraiment relax le rester
longtemps en chaque posture tu peux le
faire quand on lit la bi ton sommeil ça
va être une excellente chose ne va pas
comprendre parce que nous avec une bague
de mariage là quand je fais ces trucs le
monde et triple ou mon et survie des
centres tellement bateaux dans la nuit
puis c'est vraiment bon le moment mais
le silence y retrouviez avec l'hiver
c'est tellement plus d'ici devant un bon
sommeil
pourquoi l'exposition à la lumière des
balances un petit peu tout au niveau de
nos corps parce que c'est ce qui créait
le cortisol qui tout ceci quand
s'exposent au soleil
tu vas voir comme un genre de pique dans
ta g
ni d'énergie qui va redescendre de là à
4h ou 5h se noie en fait tout encore et
des balances mais on est vraiment forts
des disciples de survie à ses
conséquences
on n'a pas la grande - farsi place d une
heure de soleil par jour le site
allemand d'ici mais ça n'aurait rien
n'est pas que vous les lettres les
dépressions saisonnières plus de gens
qui se suicident l'hiver qu'elle était
très bataille csdl 5 février
ça fait cinq ans le 5 juin ces foules
c'était vraiment ça a été une divine
pente descendante et peut-être la
dépression ces nra med au truc la vie
sûrement mais ces foules gens moins pour
eux c'est juste ça me tient à coeur plus
jamais ma santé mentale va passer en
deuxième
parce que juste comme c'est trop
important pour moi est ce qu est ce que
tu 5
il ya un peu de dépression héréditaire
quitté quitté été transférés qui dans
qui tourne quand on a des jeux
particulièrement positive comme personne
mais j'ai réussi je le vois au niveau ma
famille comme étant ma grand-mère la
santé mentale
ll était bipolaire fait quand les gens
disent oh mon dieu tu es bipolaire à
d'autres personnes c'est comme ma grand
mère qui est décédée justement au
psychiatre il est comme c'est vraiment
deep le genre mais quelqu'un décéder à
cet endroit le mont papale qui était
latrille une dépression majeure qui
s'est suicidé ma soeur et qui est
professeur qui a vécu des moments
difficiles mais là ce avait six familles
métissées foule
chantraine simplement oui c'est
tellement content mais je pense que mes
profs je m'inscrire à fait probable
sûrement mais je pense si ce qui est moi
ce qui me patch mais il faut jamais
perdre celle là
allez c'est tellement bon pour moi puis
manger sainement
parce que je pense que beaucoup de notre
microbiote mais là c'est vraiment poussé
mais beaucoup notre santé de gesté qui
va influer sur notre humeur
si le bring feuillette comme ce qui
s'est reflété comme jeu tellement
optimisé qu'elles joueraient ce jeu
faudrait vraiment que même quand mon
père est décédé
je me suis beaucoup réfugier dans le
sport parce que ça me faisait du bien
d'elle
j'aime me laisser chez moi je trouve au
même problème des bas
un exemple de bonnes habitudes de vie la
demande
c'était comme l'élève l'entraînement de
l'alimentation pratiques optimales le
sommeil à petit-mars les 'stress test'
est vraiment bonne c'est vraiment
difficile de faire mieux qu est-ce qui
qu'est ce que tu fais quoi
c'est quoi le mot contraire du salut
cieux un cercle vertueux
un cercle vertueux puis c'est dans le
fond une fois que tu en fais j'aime et
on veut bien manger en matant jeunes
chevaux james gourlay maintenant je fais
24 kg secours 2 earl la jarrie chez nous
j'ai pas envie de claquer de la pire
marne sillas j'ai fait des haltes
arriver chez nous après monde j'aime je
me suis fait un tu te fume sauter de
tofu avec vraiment des légumes pas trop
du lte et jusqu'à vraiment un bon repos
je tiens bon super si je mange ça tous
les jours le genre serait lequel
puis là parce que tu marches sur place
et qu'un crime je me sens bien plus
petit 5 des shape le tpr et entreprendre
d'autres à faire éventuellement après ce
pic en sentant bien le niveau du 13
décembre est capable de plus gérer la
finlande à tête la tête plus claire
lebrun drogue c'est vrai le seul un
espèce de pâte heures ne pas entrer ne
pas bouger de rester chez vous dès
l'heure du repli des constamment ans
mais la cad à l'esprit vif c'est caen
qui est capable de régler tous les
dossiers
aujourd'hui je capable d'attaquer tout
ce que j'ai a attaqué deux compartiments
ta lisez tout dans ma tête de grand bien
de comprendre puis ça fait juste pas
envie de continuer mais quand tu te sens
bien les 70 plus de te sentais pas bien
pour ceux qui échangent bois crépus
d'alcool oui c'est sûr c'était une fois
qui est ressenti l'effet de pub à
l'alcool aux structures bois la critique
mais voyons qui est avant tout les faits
c'est ce silence c'est un autre cirque
comme gatif encore le dans les serres
comme virtual csn oui je te regarde ce
que tu l'utilisés personnes
on est très des trucs qu'on fait qu'on
se rend même pas compte mais tu essaies
intense le temps de peu la télé à la
maison
bon on sait justement les lions se met
en mode des erp les mots n'ont fait
plein de trucs que les gens trouvent
particulièrement bizarre
nous on est comme bien là dedans ou et
un table on était 20 ont été les deux
seuls qui buvaient pas d'alcool et c'est
le fun parce que mon père qu'on supporte
la davie on sent moins mal mais mais
bizarre qu'est ce qui est bizarre
bizarre d'avoir bien des objets qu'on
fixe cinq ans par jour le kiki éclat
piqué tu peux écrire à d'autres et ça
c'est bizarre je la vie bizarre l'élec
existait pas avant
ici ce sont des normes et des codes cd
boire de l'alcool t'es beau d'alcool
c'est pas obligatoire le jeu dc c'est
une norme sociale mais si le pont en
bois faisait pas de blizzard
mais vous c'est sûr que maintenant
quinze 15 jours mon cell je vois
maintenant marc quitte à 4 heures du
matin au bureau qui dit enfin la journée
terminée je retourne chez nous pour un
walk away peut-être qu'il est allé au
bord d'un petit peu dans le web et celle
autrefois quelqu'un est venu chez vous
le piquet marque de montres est son set
up pour ce cas on peut même pas
concevoir comment ces cdi plug ins le
skipper un truc contre ils m'ont fait
sachez comment j'aimerais organiser mes
trucs pour mes impôts m'ont fait un
logiciel qui calcule toutes les taxes
mais comme quickbooks mais version avec
ce côté de tous tes besoins
oui j'en revenais pas j'ai exprimé notre
foi j'essaie des fruits commenté nous on
fonctionne aussi pour la facturation
avec les annonceurs etc
après ce faire les follow up des
factures tout le kit le jeu prend à peu
près je peux deux ans par par semaine
c'est peut-être pour faire ce film je
vote règles et ceux de deux heures par
semaine ça par erin ses 104 heures dans
une année
oui c est parce qu'on part tellement
d'états sur des affaires qu'on se rend
pas compte qu'on peut faire tellement
mieux plus facilement oui avec des
petits trucs leucémie mais ce que j'aime
de marque ce qui selon tous qui est qu
approche une fois moi je commence pas
capables ou la technologie ce pas mon
fort cuillé comme je suis pas meilleur
que toi que je serai ce plus longtemps
pige jeu plus acharnés pich c'était
avéré je la parle je sais quoi mais pas
là
il reste longtemps sur le problème
jusqu'à temps qu'ils trouvent la
solution c'est quelque chose que je
devrais plus faire jaillir l'autre fois
et dit il rien que je serais pas capable
de faire et on y est et il n'y a rien
que je serais pas capable de faire et
dit en ce moment je préfère je serai pas
garde de construire une maison
mais si jamais je voulais apprendre à
construire une maison je serai capable
de construire une maison c'est parce que
la s qui monterait cette fois qu'il me
plaît dit construit une maison c'est pas
plus compliqué que cela
j'espère aussi que coach de combler une
connaissance complètement différent
qu'il faut que tu apprennes mais oui
absolument pas capables ou que tu crois
que tu es capable
les deux marques qui dit je suis capable
mais en réalité si pas mal tout le monde
ben oui la maison pour être capable
c'est juste fou qui disent tout dix jeux
les faits j'apprends que mal faire et la
question aussi à si c'est excessif
si c'est excessif ou casse excessif mais
ton de vouloir optimiser à l'extrême il
y aura un débalancement qui ne pas
ramener vous seriez pu bien amenée à
cause de quelque chose fact moment que
vous êtes bien j'imagine que c'est peu
mais non là je sais qu'elle son sommeil
c'est une priorité cloches comme un
géant drêche g recherche l'équilibré un
but dans notre idée taper sur les doigts
mais tu sais qui décide s'il veut pas
dormir je pense à ma avec ça mais c'est
peut-être ça va le rattraper était
justement parce que je veux vraiment
l'impression que l' équilibre entre ces
sphères le ccc solaire l'as cliff damon
en photo mais je serai là vous savez
vous quoi hier j'ai une réalisation
incroyables que le dirait jean dans le
temps mais il ya rejet petit j'ai
toujours su que le sommeil tout le monde
faisant est importante au monde six mois
un meilleur jet j'ai réalisé l'étendue à
quel point ç'a un impact à quel point ça
n'ait un impact sur tout les reste de ta
vie
qu'est ce qui s'est passé qu'est ce que
c'est bon un voyage à 23 une immense
journée supporter à 8 heures je fais des
trotteurs des road jallet nous apprêtons
à faire attention story temps avec yeah
yeah fallait je me lève comme à 7h à 8h
fall apart fera deux heures et demie de
route
j'avais une répète à québec je me fais
de la musique généraux des partis d'ici
pour aller à québec
pile au bon et j'en avais marre et pète
tout de suite après ma répétera le jeu
pas très léger avec quick à j'avais un
show que j'allais faire mon show est
apprécié au québec fecq gros journée
médecins et ça se fait qu'il ait la
veille mardi soir je vois un show et
puis ça peut ne fis n'est pas trop tard
puis à 11 heures je peux de chez nous
puis me coucher puis avoir une bonne usa
mais finalement il sait pas ce qui s'est
passé il y avait des amis on s'est mis à
boire
je me suis couché à 3 heures du matin
pis quand même chose et je me suis dit
c'est une fois je donne quand on entend
ça va aller de mangane ça va être plus
rough mais je vais y arriver
puis toutes les petites actions après sa
juste valeur le melville qui essaient
peter flux d'arrivée comme suit parti
plus tard j'étais arrivé comme vraiment
en fait jamais en retard à mama répète
ce genre de quelques minutes à cléo j'ai
comme stressé c'est au lieu des 2
juillet sera l'axé comme sébastien loeb
un peu fatigué que j'arrive leur projet
comme moins d'énergie il le mon énergie
qui est moins bonne
un effet sur l'énergie tout le monde
s'est jeté au plus haut depuis le monde
et le raïs albums sont là non ça va et
plus je parle je parlais godest j'ai
dormi trois autorités
j'essaie d'avoir de la normale mais ça
paraît pas que le monde est là comme ça
va plus on est haut et ça va mais genre
tant que l'ambiance est comme plus ou
moins à cause de ce village pas blessé
comme caisse presque semi panier les
quelqu'un bien en place les équipes et
quand je me suis levé chandail
6e manche a annoncé théâtre a marqué par
la rue à côté mais le titre jc comme tu
le trouves que je trouve le gentil le ça
commençait mal qu'il est en peluche qui
s'est jetée dans un état d'esprit
négatif parce que j'étais comme fatigué
et puis tacle après ce je vois mon show
même affaire j'arrive le peuple un tas
de l'aof plus comme je me suis pas nier
qu'ils n'ont personne ne sait rien des
jamais si c'est pas une engueulade des
genres est un pourri et monde ici et
j'aurais juste comme tu sais je t'ai pas
au genre une personne n'était pas la
personne le fun la personne ne sait ce
que t'en as big sa tête son meilleur ami
mettons la cia fait le juge afin la
journée il fait tout ce tout ce qui
s'est passé aujourd'hui sa cause que y'a
mieux prendre la bonne décision de
rentrer chez nous devant bonus mais
sachant que je me levais je peux sortir
le petit pourboire métier d'artiste
foutu dévastateur choisi notre journée
matin le pi fax et c'est ça le vrai plus
légers qu'en fait j'ai comme eric il a
tout le monde s'était excusé georges tu
es vraiment fatigué aujourd'hui piges je
t'ai pas des pigeons je m'excuse qui est
logique en fait acquis - le sommet c'est
plus important qu'on pense très
importante et une nuits huit semaines
moi je t'ai leurs gentils une nuit ça va
aller là une nuit de sommeil ça peut
vraiment avoir un impact sont pleins
phares sur tes relations sur les
relations personnelles professionnelles
tout cela était tout le temps là c'était
le serait la pire personne site est tout
le temps là dedans
dans ce mode le surtitre les soirs je le
souligne qu'à 3 heures du matin j'ai
vraiment la personne met sur le tapis
mais non mais non
c'est clair c'est vrai c'est comme nos
quatre piliers l'info tout à y penser
mais entraînement nutrition la gestion
du stress
le sommet quant à ces quatre là que tu
golay
nous n'avons bien mais ce qui est dur
c'est que juste faire ce bien ça peut
être un job à temps plein gaz mais je
pense que je pense que c'est une
question d'habitude parce que mettons
oui le sport ça prend du temps c'est le
sport ça prend du temps mais bien manger
il faut que j ai mangé quoi me tim bien
manger mettons là pour toutes les côtes
et environnemental environnementaux
négatifs mais ton il ya des façons de
que ce soit vraiment plus simples comme
marché good food
puis ces affaires là dessus des services
de repos que tu te fais livrer chez vous
là ils vont avoir des attentes hâtive
plus écologique
ce podcast et sponsors mais frêche je
suis passé que les autres mais mettez ce
jeu c'est faisable
ouais toi tu fais oui il ya des options
il ya des suspensions de la fin après ce
même le stress le job à temps une fois
qu'ils maîtrisent comment gérer ce ça va
bien et puis le sommeil aussi l'été fait
finalement c'est quand de prendre
l'habitude ces cuisines et je voudrais
que tu cuisines la crap ou de quoi qui
est bon c'est sûr que si tu fais livrer
tu peux te faire livrer de quoi qui est
bon s'il tue parce que les restos que
c'est de la merde c'est pas parce que
c'est un resto que c'est pas bon pour la
santé
toutes les resteront des options qui
sont bonnes pour la santé je pense que
les fier j'ai lu ça va être extrêmement
inquiète pardon c'est un militaire qui
arrivait en face on prend tellement pas
une chips pascual mots en français
responsabilité oui on prend tellement
peur responsable est à bout hu
autant responsabilité nos actions qu'ils
ont mais ce sera la faute de l'autre
pions on dirait que tout est notre focus
pas tout mais la plupart de nos décision
découle des nos choix découle de nos
décisions ont fait que je pense que
arrêter de faire des excuses de blanc
mais l'iso d'edx pas facile pas facile
pour personne mais mon petit fond les
ultras obèses et court un ultramarathon
c'est lui c'est la personne le mandat le
plus fort ben du moins je sais pas si je
sais pas si tout ce qu'il dit et est
exact moi j'ai l'impression que d'entrer
dans son discours il exagère pour faire
mieux passer son message mais les faire
reste demeure le pire mais c'est le
gueut le plus motivant tu peux écouter
c'est troublant à quel point c'est une
machine voit ce qu'il peut accomplir un
centième de ce qui met quelqu'un dit
quand il parle de l'entraînement comme
black de la corne pour l'esprit galice
for your mind flex et s'entraîne pour
qui apprécie vient du plus fort pis j'y
moi c'est comme ça que je vois quand je
vais quand je vais au jim je décide de
me donner une crise le genre de me
défoncer le genre de faire un espèce de
week end de course de pas possible ben
je le fais je repose les peco marathon
et je veux pas faire des records je peux
gagner aucun marathon et e-bay les
charges
ce bateau l'aude pas si longtemps le
tien mais je les fais juste pour me
rincer moi même je le peux juste pour
faire genre pour que mon esprit 10 à mon
corps c'est moi qui choisis on y chante
aux toiles des gestes pouvoir faire
c'est d'aller se rincer ou jim analyse
se faire gronder ne pas recourir pour
manger
et comme moi j'ai très peu sont un enjeu
ce genre d'option gpo temps de fun mais
je vais capacités je la sentais paul on
se sait moi ça me donne la motivation de
le faire prendre le temps est
reconnaissant pour le corps qu'on a
présentement de ces poubelles mais
répond de la scrap suite donné la scop
est ce que tu mérites de la scrap n'ont
fait moi je peux de la scrap tout le
temps c'est des fois oui à qui sait les
qu'il aimait très potes encore comme 7
d'or
prends soin de toi est important c'est
tout comme si c'était la chance d'avoir
une machine qui fonctionne bien et y
passent que tel est le concept de
responsabilité chez totalement d'accord
avec simon a quand même tous un contexte
des balises qui ont été terminés ces
dames minimes différent il y en a qui
vont être avec plus de chance ou plus de
dans un contexte plus favorable que
d'autres
sauf quand même dans l'avenir contre
mais tout le monde sait tout le monde
pour faire mieux en guillemette selon
l'entraîneur les axes qui régit qui sont
hors de son contrôle
tout le monde sait ça c'est pas la
question d'être de se comparer aux
autres
comparé à toi mais est-ce que je suis
meilleur que moi your exact c'est la
bonne question à se poser
je suis meilleur que moi hier sur plaine
niveau skill une meilleure nuit de
sommeil qu'hier ce que je capable de
m'améliorer surtout si toutes ces points
le personnellement comparaison mai
tout le monde il faut gagner quand
qu'ils aident non mais cet été je voyais
une psy à guy piste était que si
justement défaut de vouloir bien faire
toutes les choses que devient une
pression qu'on se met ce devient un
stress c'est de vouloir imperfections de
vouloir la perfection de vouloir que
tout ses six frères le web soit bonne il
faut je m'entraîne
il faut il faut y rajouter toujours des
iphone ça devient un stress fax et la
difficulté je trouve des capable de de
tout faire bien les choses le met dans
un harmonie dans un équilibre qui
devient pas une pression
j'ai passé par là avec la nutrition
c'est avec les compétitions de fitness
mais comme j'avais une feuille piste
écrit 30 ans g des sites en gramme de
suspects valley qui suit à la lectrice
heures l'après quand j'ai pu fait ce
chiffre hors tu sais que je m'écris y
ait des règles des limites pied pour
tenter je capable de bien manger lui
même ce qu'on mange jeu payet plus ça
changerait puisse de postes qui rappe et
ajourner parce que de manger un bout de
chocolat s'est fait qu'il faut pas
tomber dans une soie négative ou scom se
tapissent a atteint et justement quand
on est pauvre parfait ouais c'est des
fois ça se peut que tu avais pas tu
puisses pas au jam journée c'est quand
même souvent le trop trop souvent pour
ce que moi j'aimerais mais ça arrive le
tir aujourd'hui maintenant lors de
podcasts ont imité après tignes en
alsace peu qu'aujourd'hui j'avais peur
jean ou que j'y aille ce soit vraiment
léger mais tu sais si tu veux vraiment
faire de l'entraînement d'après rtl
objective à le faire marcher piste avait
un objectif à court terme le paquet mali
rita journée très pris le temps petit
souci de respecter son corps trous en
formule trop s'entraîner un peu mieux et
est à 10 est au point qu'ils
c'est toutefois n'en vis pas mieux les
troubles de céleri ce pommier unique
mais y'a juste à l'isle adam ouais c'est
quand même bon goût de notre affaire ça
m'arrive maintenant mais ça on en a
parlé et quand leur super nanny
catherine les nutritionnistes
on a parlé après le podcast de la
nutrition intuitive dans ce sens que si
tu es vraiment l'écoutent de ton corps
piste un travail ce serait pas
facilement mais c'était vraiment les
coûts de ton corps tu devrais
naturellement tourné vers se sentir bien
puis puis justement si tu prends le
temps de voir si tu marches vraiment
rapidement peut-être mangé plus qu est
ce que tu es ce que tu es signaux
société vu qu'on peut le temps
d'embarquer vu que tu as besoin de
manger ti et inversement quand aux fins
selon soute devrait manger tout sauf que
c'est sur ces pistes puis justement se
tourner vers les aliments sains et
apparemment mais apparemment ça
fonctionne vraiment quand tu lui quand
il travaillait il développe quatre
quantité que de vraiment ainsi que drame
en fait de créer des caisses de santé
c'est que ton corps a besoin d'aller
chercher sintra le parlement a dit
quelque chose qui pousse à aller vers le
défaut on crève aussi des trucs vraiment
pas santé ouais mais c'est ça fait quand
même des fois même temps a souvent
j'avais envie m'attendre
coline frites sauce le mais là
maintenant c'est comme des fois chez
nous puisse faire à qui je regarde
frigo.com pas ce que j'aurais besoin
pour ya plutôt fumée temps un frigo
parce qu'il ya une pénurie tokyo québec
en soit c'est vraiment construit mais il
y en a pas mal frigo peut me dire je me
ferais livré jean imbs le frère je ferai
en sauter men c'est qu'est ce qui existe
à montréal que j'ai découvert qu'il
existait génie montréal il peut leur
demander n'importe quoi n'importe quoi
même mois deux chameaux il va t'amener
douche à mon esprit demander n'importe
quoi si elle a fait livrer des trucs
j'en attends tu maintenant il ya passé
on n'est même pas you marry non mais on
l'a au bureau mais peu et qui a pas
vraiment une sélection incroyablement
cette coupe létévé ce coin là chaque
fois que je veux c'est tellement mollo
genre savate a considéré parce qu'ici
évidemment le studio y est loin quand
adam nord y est loin ici du studio mais
j'habite à côté mais éventuellement
besoin souvent aux morts et environ
saint-jérôme c'est à dix minutes de la
montagne de saint sauveur jambes 4 c'est
vraiment ça me fait vraiment penser
genre à stoneham au qatar et dans ce cas
il a un sens c'est comme quand je cours
je me sens comme l'histoire si jeanne y
ait un beau parc aussi protégé dans mon
coin
si le lac gironde les gens connaissent
même pas si on a accès gratuitement puis
c'est une boucle de 4 km dans l'eau avec
un lac à moi tu sais c'est comme une
boucle de 4 km en bois c'est parfait
c'est la meilleure chose pour qui un lac
comment à 2.131 mètres c'est comme moi
petit continent courent effet justement
est reconnaissante commun sur pied andré
je sais pas moralement je la misère je
paye comme anti montréal mais plein de
trucs comme de montréal que je pense
qu'il fonctionnerait pas avec mon pied
j'ai besoin des deux gros des armes de
me sentais proche d'un autre oeil tout
les week ends fait des randonnées avec
moi si vous êtes si vous êtes proche de
tremblant proche de moi j'aime ça mais
c'est pas pour tout le monde qu'il ya
des gens qui adorent montréal puis je
respecte ça mais moi je serai pas car
j'ai vite eu toute ma vie ce serait pas
énorme
notre âge tu m as passé ta nature est
vraiment d expérience en fait le pitre
aux caves du musée riche de menton
niveau de stress demande encore répond
plus juste passer une journée nature ça
c'est encore ça change complètement
l'été c'est dur de me rentrer dans la
maison comme je resterai je vais
déjeuner dehors j'ai travaillé avec mon
métier j'essaye j'aime juste trop je
fais des marches avec mon chien comme
pour s2 en fait je pourrais je suis
jamais revenu parce que j'aime tellement
ça dort il va un peu moins mais je vais
quand même et c'est plus rough pour les
chiens
et pour moi il ya un pack à stoke
s'appelle reach rôle que j'aime vraiment
beaucoup le site un athlète d'ultra
endurance qui y gagnent pire choix du
monde parlement que tu aimerais vraiment
celui du mans qui ont des idées qui
parle de méditation qui parle de
nutrition vegan qui parle de plan
d'affaires qui lui-même son discours par
rapport aux sports d'ultra endurance il
dissipe a pourtant c'est pas pour
l'entraînement que tu le fais c'est
juste pour qui est à l'honneur
des fois il fait des défenses semaine ce
qui porte un char lui tant qu'elle
fournit le plus con d'huile dans une
place de parc national le plus distantes
le pays court mais j'arrive pour 80 kg
plat des fois tu vois il calme en train
de filmer il fait jour elle
genre je suis rendu à telle place à
regarder autour de moi plus monde sa
came rotours le pis débile c'est débile
ce qui fait le saut à skis et pili place
pie xii de l'air comme ce ça trop de
bien fait c'est trop bon pour la tête
pour l'esprit pour le corps et puis moi
depuis que je suis à verdun puis que je
peux courir ce bord du fleuve
ça fait une énorme différence avant je
courrais dans le parc frédéric back
michel loin c'est ça c'était vraiment un
beau parc c'était 5 km 5.5 de bouc le
thé avec la gravelle fait pour que la
course était parfait mais crise si c'est
un ancien dépotoir
c'est le mieux que c'est mieux que
montréal peut pouvait offrir pour le
genre de course que je pouvais faire
mais maintenant que tavernost mi-course
le bord du fleuve c'est un monde
différent comme le fleuve billère mais
c'est tous les jours je vais dans le
bois la côte est chinoise
le bois c'est une soirée sur sam surtout
après beaucoup tant dans leur division
ils veulent être vais je recharge et ça
me prend pas grand chose l'un des gens
qui font le grand ring avait vu son nom
mais tes pieds nus dans sur le seul dans
ma baignoire santé l'énergie de la terre
s'apprêter ni rejet de guérir et pour
échanger des livres at-il groening que
ça s'appelle ça sonne un peu comme le
monde qui se met la neige au soleil
[Rires]
je n'ai rien j'attends ce jeu subit jour
j'ai réécouté sceptiques assez exigeant
que je me dis c'est ce que juste prendre
le temps de s'arrêter web
c'est sûrement ce que ça prend le temps
s'arrêter puis georges c'est comme
respirer puis genre c'est sûr que c'est
bon mais est-ce que ça va être guérir la
maladie fait un câlin
mindset dans lequel tu me croit quand je
pense que ça apparaisse ton esprit
l'esprit maison mais moi je pense qu'il
fasse mon esprit qu'est non mais quand
tu déposes t2 - sur du bois parce qu'il
ya une côte est mais dit à ses fans je
prends le temps de ressentir
puis j'ai commencé ici j'ai entendu
parler en fait j'ai entendu parler j'ai
découvert les montres ou dernièrement
puis j'ai commencé à essayer de me
prêter au jeu le juste me répéter un mot
ou un mineur est ce que tu es un mot
choisi bâle 3 10 une suite de son insu
fait que je puis je me répète une suite
de son âme attaquant et un président qui
tourne le regard de faire le vide
je me répète une suite de mots parlant
comme trois minutes mais les motos
l'important c'est d'y croire est
techniquement un montreur je le fête
donnée par quelqu'un mettons ça peut
être un maïs cèdent 1,1 m maintenant
tout en maintenant tu m'amènes j'suis
pas l'exemple que j'ai vu c'est amène
trois objets puis le tchèque les objets
puisque ça veut dire pour tous appelés
données montrent maintenant cha doo-ri
way serait pas consulté c'est ça qui
fait que ses proches a duré mais
maintenant je pas gagné non plus avec la
matante affaires qui se présentent à
taipei de ce fait juste répéter à data
chacun sommes entre eux puis il faut
passer messages galanta taille puis
c'est quand même quelque chose qui va
réussir à faire le vide car mes tantes
ou 5 le stress mon [ __ ] t'es tu
arrives dans un moment de d'anxiété ou
de pagnes et qui est lié aux à la charge
mentale ou annie à ce pilote fait juste
de répéter ça fait que tu pense à rien
d'autre sur ce ça met tout sur pause
mais
c'est souvent itunes à répétition est en
sanskrit tout cela la langue
l'ancienne langue en inde qui est c'est
tous des trucs répétitif puisse
accueillir vraiment ont même pas ce que
tu peux pas penser à tout qu'est-ce qui
titrait ces inquiétudes parce que c'est
tellement une boucle quand on est comme
des petits robots le ch'ti peiné quand
j'écoute ça à l'élève tellement mon
énergie pieds dans l'eau touchent mais
ce que je fais du ménage mais son petit
modèle mais c'est vraiment de l'or quand
j'ai pris cap spotify de la nuit tout
nous est juste des voix et comme les
gayatri mantra est assez tôt main c'est
comme des tricks et spirituelle
quand tu sais qu est ce que ça veut dire
c'est encore plus plus à pied moi j'aime
vraiment ce qu'il faut j'ai fait jouer
tout le monde mais ça change tout puis
des phrases scénario tout fonctionne
comme ça devrait fonctionner mettons
qu'il quoi qui titrait dans la vie tu
peux juste se répéter ça dans ta tête
tout fonctionne comme ça devrait
fonctionner tout fonctionne comme ça
devrait fonctionner c'est con mais ça
fait du bien on est tellement pensé
d'inquiétude ça s'achète notre réalité
fait que je pense qu'il est juste se
conditionner à faire un exercice comme
ça ça peut vraiment nous aider à prendre
nos esprits puis transformé en quelque
chose de plus positif
du moins quand je travaille puis je
ramasse et concentré je me mets vraiment
un jeu mais justement la musique
extrêmement répétitif comme seul sait le
scam juste mais ça s'appelle instrus
bits ce serait à porter new zik puis
c'est jusqu'à
de la parole dont il ya eu quelques
variations des fois le méca je veux
vraiment maintenant faire une période de
focus intense les os qui est le média
qui est léger deux heures pour faire de
quoi que j'ai besoin de forêt outils qui
font que ça me reste concentré les mets
ça pis pour vrai
je tourne pas mon regard de ma tâche
pendant ces deux jours là y'a rien qui
vient dans ma tête pendant ce temps là
rien qui rend le matin qui a rien qui
sort il y aurait il sauve comme mon
contact avec le travail que j'enfonce ma
main
rien rien d'autre léger pas de penser
des comanches de jeu sous sol justin il
s'était défendu dès stress ou d'aider
des trucs qui nous apparaissent des
montagnes puis de sa petite affaire
comme ça ça peut justement remettre en
contexte soupe respectives et en
perspective la farce et puis tu te des
péages avez lu les plongeurs de ses fans
l'art une victoire qui est un excellent
roman jamais sans intérêt puis les
personnages yeux comme un deadline est
quelque chose arts mais il faut qu'ils
fassent ce qu'ils aillent là la pochette
d'un album
pis tout le long du livre il fait pop
est arrivée à la ferme et le fidèle à
lapproche [ __ ] approche plus c'est
comme une espèce de de stress immense
dans sa vie pid alsace a été le genre
jeu repose jamais capable ça puis à
réalité enfin ce punch ni rien bad boy
il remet jamais tripes il fait pau puis
oui ça ça fait chier ça fait chier tout
le monde put se mais en bout de ligne
après seuil est encore en vie dans le
sens qu'ils étaient il ya des choses qui
m'apparaissent comme c'est la fin du
monde qui en réalité c'est pas la fin du
monde la vie va continuer même si tu
échoues quelque chose même si c'est pis
je dis pas qu'il faut août et se laisser
aller puis pour respecter nos
engagements mais jusqu'ici
jusqu'à 10 de la fac on stresse
tellement prêt à faire la paix en
réalité c'est pas si grave que ce genre
c'est pas une question de vie ou de mort
n'est pas en train de faire une
opération à coeur ouvert le judo de pas
en train de dire des bêtises mais
mettons quand je vivais dans les titres
je comprends pas moi mais maintenant je
comprends mais c'est quand tu es dedans
le c'est vraiment une autre game puis si
je pense que quand même en est bien fait
mais pourquoi on se fait des loupes dans
la taille pourquoi on se fait des
scénarios pourquoi on fait des
inquiétudes
on veut se préparer au pire qui pourrait
arriver on met ça nous bloque ça ne met
les deux pieds dans le ciment qui ont
fait peu d'action quand on fait des
actions d'habitude on sent mieux mais
depuis quand tu es juste rester lente
ait pensé à aux mondiaux je serai jamais
capable de mettre des pensées limitantes
par rapport à attiser objectif puis oui
il ya une question que je me pose par
rapport à cette aventure c'est ce
fardeau de choses lesquels il ya une
spark j'aimerais que toi et marque
peut-être est moins importante pour vous
mais pour d'autres mais paraît sera
important c'est le voyant la sphère
sociale les amis le ton est juste passé
pas d'amis mais tu y vas paraissait pas
précis comme du monde qui reste et
surtout à la maison faite aux affaires
vous n'êtes pas toujours entouré de 1000
personnes qui justement à sortir puis à
faire des soirées entre amis que je me
trompe mais andrée j'ai des traits ses
lectrices je dis mes amis ça fait des
années que je connais pied je sais je
publie pas tant sur les réseaux
mais mes relations d'amitié parce que
justement ça m'impressionne pour moi
mais oui on est très
et on aime c'est resté dans autre chose
à la maison sont rentrés heureux
chipoter pour nous il ya bonheur dans un
super pour d'autres commandes de ces
plates sortait pas vendredi samedi
nous on est ko on aime tellement ses
mais j'aime ça allait faire une
randonnée ce qui m'excite le changer
notamment rendu dimanche le fait que
c'est les petits bonheurs c'est la vie
c'est de retrouver la joie dans les
petites rues parce que c'est moche
fasciné je te vois par les gens qui ont
l'air bien parce que j'essaie de
m'inspirer de ce but d'essayer de
comprendre comment ils y ont trouvé ce
bien être loupé sa bonne arabe c'est
qu'ils puissent souvent si des gens qui
sont très bien entouré qui est très bon
cercle puis quand on allie bonne
personne un bon certes mais c'est
surtout des bonnes personnes et
personnes en être victimes qui nous
amène pas voir le loup qui est vraiment
des gens pacifiques et comme les ménages
ont le fait pas et bleu c'est un jeu
vraiment juste des bonnes personnes dans
nos vies pied c'est le fun vraiment
content je serai connaissent moi je me
je me reconnais beaucoup dans ce que tu
dis j'ai pas ça fait longtemps que j'ai
pas eu un nouvel ami j'ai vraiment été
un bon ami que je veux voir le même
chercheur dammipi da titre le tpiy je
comprends le feeling de dire samedi si
ça me soit on ne peut sortir moi ça me
va très bien
ça va très bien parce que sinon je
fatigue et le lendemain je lui tends la
main chez moi je suis un gars de faire
mes affaires puis au final
j'imagine que je sais pas si je
m'imagine que je sais pas trop comment
exprimer ce jeu un petit cocon si je
sais pas c'est en coupe ça fait une
différence mais ce que me départir son
pied
ton petit univers et puis je sais bien
là dedans mettez j'aime sortir
temps en temps mais je suis que oui j'ai
beaucoup plus de confort puis ça ne fait
pas les firmes et senior non plus
osheaga ch russo belle phone mais si je
veux pas ça mange pas vu j'ai pas
l'impression de manquer quelque chose
peut être coude et je pense que c'est
quelque chose qui peut être vraiment
intéressant à exploiter parce que serait
partout en même temps mais jamais bien
comme avec toi mais mou puis c'est en
exemple capable mais je peux pas
m'éparpiller me sentir centre et si je
peux pas être à gauche puis à droite
pyatt est l'événement qui a si bien su
quand même priorité sur les choses
importantes pied nous avons priorisé le
dit qu'outre le petit cocon qui n'espère
la santé différent de ce que les autres
personnes funky justement social boit de
l'alcool et chuté depuis que ça fait
deux semaines le conte les lundis ou
mardis on joue à donjons dragons ici là
à la surprise dans son visage c'était
minute loïc on est un groupe ii si on
est deux mois de six pieds trois autres
de noël j'ai pu nous on vient faire ses
anneaux c'est quand je me dis le seul
c'est vraiment mon genre d'interactions
sociales que j'ai qu'il fait ça en
devenait genre une hebdomadaire les deux
phares qui checke ce synode lundi le
lundi en face au pis on voit nos amis
c'est sur ce dragon l'asie c'est le fun
parce que maintenant on se voit une fois
semaine pile en fin de séance mais tout
ça c'est une grande
partis cités qui comme une histoire mais
qui peut durer indéfiniment à peu près à
une campagne complète ça dure à peu près
3 4
salut farissi musées sont permis pour
apprendre les pleureuses un bob parker
il va parler mais je sais c'était moins
que peu de temps mais je sais pas on
devrait trancher jeune j'ai pas beaucoup
joué les le toc est ce que vous
connaissez ça à mes amis sont
compétitives ainsi cet été on joue et je
perdais tout le temps mais ça me
dérangeait pas mais je comprends c'est
juste trop rapides qu'ils réalisent
c'est quelque chose qui manque à la
maison pour ne pas de jeux de société
aurait j'ai acheté des jeux de société
ça c'est chez nous parce que oui je aux
cartes des trucs comme ça c'est vraiment
un mais grand papa et grand maman qui
font ça mais j'aimais ce camp cherche
vraiment très jeunes jouent aux cartes
avec ma grand-mère et des trucs et on
devrait jouer plus oui oui je suis
d'accord qu'il est juteuse était
techniquement c'est une autre groupe un
ami pour jouer à quelque chose
ces hôtels il est très calme montréal
comme à une place que des jeux de
société barnabé randolph riddle france
je trouve ça va vraiment cool parce
qu'il sait proposer des jeux qui ont
toutes les joueuses comme le paradis des
jeux en tous cas quelque chose sans toi
je me souviens pas que je les voyais
quelque chose que je voulais qu'on parle
chaud ça va intéresser nos news de stars
la chirurgie oui surtout fameux bruce
timm plantes
ils naissent chez que c'est quelque
chose qui est tout temps à parler quand
même
puis c'est quelque chose qui intéresse
principalement j'imagine les gens qui
vont dicter sur youtube le chic c'est
quelque chose que les gens se posent
beaucoup de questions parce que c'est
quoi il ya quelques années des gens ont
commencé à dire qu'il ressentait
desmarez par rapport aux implants mais
c'est beaucoup de symptômes en lien avec
les implants que les gens avaient peu
avant des feux se faire poser des
implants puis l idée d un groupe de
femmes qui écrit un groupe facebook qui
le rendait plus de cent mille personnes
je pense dans ce groupe le et un groupe
ici et maintenant et franco-canadien
l'information s'est fait denis pleyel
beaucoup plus de chirurgie n'implante
plus timide puis d'implants mammaires
parce qu'ils y ont ré semblement vu que
ça crée des rails son auto immunes chez
les femmes qui étaient comme nous les
gens qui font retirer ses implants
on n'est pas comme compte les uns
plantes on veut juste qu'il ya une
information qui est des gens pour est
malade est ce qu a eu des études qui ont
été faites suite à six espèces de
témoignages témoignages le web parce que
je veux dire c'est dans ce que le sait
vraiment acide témoignage pour que ya un
cas c'est un vrai questionnement le spo
comme certaines de la foire qui
n'utilisent pas comme la vitamine c
vitamine c et il doit ce qu'il ya pas
vraiment de témoignages le site web et
scientifiquement l'anecdote de chacune
des personnes au pôle valeur
scientifique mais quatre éditions çà
c'est pour qu'un questionnement picon
qu'on veuille investiguer enfin que je
sais pas ce qu'il dit maintenant de base
les implants les études qui ont été
faites pour dire que c'était safe et ont
pas été mené à terme ou les participants
et hafiz est pas là au complet et il ya
vraiment plein de lacunes au niveau des
études a qui disent oui c'est save
pleurs récemment ya un type d'implant
qui étaient retirés du marché suite à
des éléphants
il se sentait pas bien de la mda je
pense à semaine passée tous les implants
peuvent en les symptômes peuvent causer
le cancer aux états unis way
la clé c'est un des trucs qui va était
inscrit hier consulaires les bols des
implants quantité est implanté mais nous
on aimerait que juste les gens fassent
un choix plus éclairés pid savent qu'il
ya des risques et moi c'est que j'allais
rejet camille dintrans carrément c'est
ce qu'ont cherché avait tout temps les
sinus comme si mon corps vous laisse
base j'avais des rush des allergies
alimentaires parce que mon corps était
jusqu en compte mes implants et gésir et
hippie ma vie a changé de camp même
temps sur deux ans je suis vraiment
contente laisse comme une des meilleure
décision de ma vie j'ai plein d'autres
ça faisait combien d'entre eux et trois
ans et sept mois aucun doute de la
relation cause à effet moi ça fait juste
dix ans lettre d'un plant quelque chose
d'être toxiques dans ton corps tu penses
avoir rien fait quelque chose qui est
encore le cas jurassique la respiration
la respiration quelque chose à celle où
l'on peut dire qu'ils sortent en chef
sont à poitrine tout le temps puis aux
stocks implante un implant il va avoir
une capsule qui se forment pour protéger
ton corps de l'implant des jeunes est
encore réagi ça vaut bien qu'ils aient
même si un mois son halo salinité de
l'eau saline je pense en branle de
l'ovalie mais l'accueil de l'implant et
comme je peux combien de composantes
chimiques pour créer tous de quel type
de blanc j'avais su à l'oustal au sol
entre les pensées watch qui est en
silicone muffins réactions seront
sûrement points
c'est 5 mais eux c'est un peu d'avoir
fait ses choix leur petite hutte et auto
rendu malade mais ne l'a pas fait en
connaissance pas parce que mais dans la
dernière fois quand je t'ai vu quelqu'un
se dévoue aux marathons qui avec le
temps on en a parlé un petit peu puis
vous avez dit que entre éveillant de
l'opération
c'était comme s'il y avait un monde de
changement déjà juste le poids sur ma
poitrine c'est comme c'est gentil dans
la pire situation l'association jaquette
avec des cicatrices et comme pas ce que
c'était
c'est de l'eau saline fait l'os cassé
l'appareil de deux grosses boules 12,6
toi le qui traînent partout de la korité
temps mais discret que j'ai pu mais un
plan qui est des gens qui ont des
intentions oripeaux 2010 d'une
perspective mettons extraterrestres et
pourquoi on n'y reste pas mettre des
trucs sous la peau pour avoir l'air plus
cute selon dans leur beauté conventions
sociales
pis même type comme j'ai repensé comme
on dit que c'est pas moi le tiche jeu
m'a pas pourquoi j'ai fait ses pions on
est tellement belle comment ni le projet
le crois vraiment qu'ils montent chez
nous il voulait que je fasse mettre des
implants
il faut juste comme ça c'est avec alors
qu'entre le fait 21 ans au quai 21 ans
puis est ce que tu avais je pose puisque
analyser les raisons qu'il faut savoir
se nommait mai puis je porte aucun
jugement là dessus puis jusqu'au bateau
mais départ comme ses potes avait dessus
une confiance en toi plus fragiles à
l'époque avait dessus ce jeu c'est pas
le pis je peux dire que si tu fais sauce
parce que t'es pas comme un toit mais
c'est qu'est ce qui t'a poussé ma tante
mes enfants chez leur ancien milieu qui
était beaucoup plus
mais chez dans un milieu justement les
compétitions de fitness qui s est
montrée axé sur le physique et beaucoup
d'autres femmes avaient des implants et
de mon pourcentage de reuil variés
facture à 2005 p comme fatigant les
genres j'avais des saints of season pass
que je prenais du grand quand je montais
ce ces gens n'avaient pu que je me
sentais pas féminine parce que j'ai
musclé moins de st avec le gif et même
des implants pour comme et régler les
problèmes dans le fond et je réalise que
ça fait rire entre logement
j'ai parlé plus gros seins étaient plus
petits seins ou peu importe mais si ça
me dérange pas mais oui j'avais un
certain complexe et j'aurais pas mis un
maillot comme je porte présentement
l'équipe
maintenant je réalise que ma féminité
c'est vraiment plus que une partie de
mon corps même je me sens plus féminine
en ayant tout mon corps qui en ayant des
poches d'eau et salines outils de granby
les gens qui ont des symptômes
sérieusement c'est triste parce que je
me fait écrire à toutes les semaines que
c'est pas correct et si je veux le faire
mettre des implants mais il ya des
risques auditifs d'autres jupiter un
pater c'est ok ok l'italie de cépie la
personnalité tu parlais en avait aussi
perdu qu'un match touche du bois parce
que j'en ai potes et fac est factice et
je pense que chaque corps réagit
différemment si tu pourras mars à voir
mais mais tu peux savoir que ces gestes
s'implanter les trucs comme ça
beaucoup de
un truc qu'on fait qu'un composteur au
test de l'extra terrestre
oui c'est ce qu'ils sont vraiment des
affaires qu'on fait ou est ce qu'un
extraterrestre de baxi bref c'est un
milieu qui encouragent et ce parce que
tu sais il y en avait beaucoup qui jeta
massa sa force avoir aucun regret donc
compenser une certaine manière c'est l'
équilibre l'esthétisme c'est comme si tu
écris son spa muscler son autre corps tu
t'es pas autant de volume
ce composé est ce comme décrit les
espèces de symétrie ocampo accord mais
le ces fameux celle ci s'était plus de 5
ça fait plus avec ton pote comme si on
s'entend que le corps déjà l'air à la
base c'était du gros il va te donner
autant d'enjeux 4,5 ou thé dans la peau
du cul devant moi il ya des différents
types de morphologie métier la raison
pourquoi j'avais pas de sens parce que
j'avais pas de gros fait que j'en tire
pas sa période la vie est ce que c'est
qui c'est quoi le sentiment qui jaillit
ses côtés de fierté dessus pourquoi j'ai
fait ça tu sais quoi comment tout ça par
rapport à cette phase le bikini finesse
pêche pas géniale peut s'adonner
négative maintenant quand je sortais
chez mais j'ai perdu l'argent tempier g
je me suis investi dans un sport comme
ça mais maintenant je pense que c'est
c'est vraiment beaucoup discipline ça
m'a beaucoup appris
le dépassement de soi puis de
l'optimisation
mais bien sûr ce que des compétitions de
santé réalisée pour ma vie 1
pour le futur je fais des trucs pour ma
santé pour être plus en cher aux yeux
des autres aux yeux d'un juge
si je le fais pour moi les vrais
chiffres
c'est ce qui parlait justement la
différence entre un sport jugé pour un
sport où est ce que tu as une valeur
objective ou l'envié d'aller plus vite
de télé moins vite pis les personnes de
tableaux milk toi-même il ya paul u2
je suis rendu j'ai décidé à un humain et
plus rapide c'est-à-dire après en
allemand ou marathon de québec
c'était ma deuxième année je le faisais
puis comme j'ai descendu de 22 minutes
le démontre le coup j'ai fait arriver je
m'étais pas senti de même depuis depuis
un vraiment gros bâtiments la dation là
où est ce que je me suis dit kim je me
suis objectivement vraiment à cette
affaire comme cette affaire le team et
ont des cartes et rendu le gentil toi
guide mettons la salle était difficile
de voir mais ton est là je me suis
vraiment amélioré afin que ça qui est
comme au jeu tant contrôle ça va pas
aimer ou est peut-être que je peux plus
je suis un peu plus en contrôle
c'est quand je suis vraiment meilleurs
pas que ce milieu là mais d'être au
milieu et ses 2,5 au milieu ou seuil et
où quand comment le décrire les débuts
d'une préparation c'est environ deux
semaines d'une préparation à une
compétition jusqu'à la mois ci c'est
très sain même ces gens là sont hyper en
santé mais je rêve
walking feuilleton mettant le 12
semaines mais c'est le cas des parts du
groupe optimise mais si c'est la fin
c'est pas normal pour une fille d'abord
10% grelots les gens tebi certains est
certain c'est que si je sais tout les
broccolis ce serait essentielle qui est
sûr le kop la nutrition c'est pas assez
variés puis cédé des interdits
alimentaires au sujet du rpt travailler
là dessus parce que c'est comme qui
souhaitait pas loin de mon jeu se remet
tomber et légumes sont pas au vert c'est
moins bon
sans aller manger une carotte c'est
comme si comme tricher avec un rôle mais
comme rarement ces petits tout les
interdits dès qu'il y ait des gens qui
ont un rebond après la confession qui me
reprendre 30 livres anciens et neufs
mois que c'est bon pour la santé
je pense qu est ce qui est bon c'est
justement te maintenir d'avoir une belle
condition physique tout au long l'année
ces cantons pourcentage dreuil et ball
est il normal et les gens qui perdent la
monstration dans les filles lakers
étaient beaucoup de dopage accepté mais
comme et bikinis comme moi il ya une
condition que si c'etait pas testé à
consentants titre garder la matrix
jusque là une fille de 25 ans au moins
d'avancer natixis c'est accepter mais ça
vaut toutes les hormones puis quand
c'est mal fait jamais de chasse mais
heureusement parce qu appliquer ma santé
serait vraiment ce cas présentement mais
les gocistes et les hormones peas après
capable de concevoir réussite et
ailleurs
ce n'est pas normal mais c'est pas des
sports de compétition santé et des gens
qu'ils font santé ils sont peut-être des
haies des génériques incroyable mais je
veux le faire je tama en ayant un bon
équilibre puis en d'état santé tu seras
pas le meilleur mais peut-être au niveau
ici est régionale provinciale mais quand
tu arrives et les autres compétitions
nationales b soit vraiment un taillis et
il le fitness vraiment c'est beau la
discipline mais ça peut devenir
justement qu'on tombe dans l'extrême ses
lacs ses plus beaux buts
par catégorie de poids vif ici par
grandeur ouaga bah ouais ok puis proches
d'enfants liés
2 les seniors je passais quel âge
exactement le genre catégorie à ses cinq
pieds entre le tas fait preuve
actuellement pour le fun ou tu en as
fait ça parce que tu es ma dernière
comme préparation je m'étais dit âge
j'aimerais sa propre santé je pense
qu'ils arrivèrent la moitié la
préparation j'ai vu que c'était de santé
j'ai entré j'ai eu l'est chez maintenant
je porte en ce sens n'a pas tort mais et
andrey j'avais comme et un espoir que
j'allais être capable de le faire
seulement pied des taillis est inchangée
tout changement tu t'isoles plus studien
comme plus et je peux commander cette
suite dans ton plein pithiviers un peu
plus
obsessed moi j'aime possémé comme si
j'aime c'est manger de façon indue
siffle je faisais plus ceux qui la
pression était à qui tu pars pas à ses
pieds si tu aimes faire prendre ton
pourcentage des grog
mais faire définir par un pourcentage de
reçus au nom je suis retrouvé là non je
voudrais question c'est est-ce un tel a
parlé beaucoup de côté physique d'après
sur tous ces mécanismes le tout ces
choses le mental qui te fait un culte
une façon ça doit être long se défaire
de ses réflexes l'appareil beaucoup de
troubles alimentaires cette compétition
de moitié je suis j'ai touché mais tiges
pas de tomber dans un trouble mental
mais j'ai des amis que oui c'est débile
shearing fait de manger des parce que tu
écoutes tellement petit signaux de faim
pendant la préparation
tu te reste un tel manque après tt comme
toi un interdit alimentaire et manger
impunité lots complets hostilités comme
ça qu'ils font aucun sens mais qu'elle
est bien gidding les gosses c'est comme
la piqûre eksi s'est que trop jamais
assez gros jamais assez
chips rien miroiter comme marc judic
erasme se trouve peau et en shape tandis
que tu es folle enchère aussi une dalle
distorsion oui carrément
si vous voulez faire des coupes et je
sais que j'ai comme dans le passé les
gens étaient inspirés pu ou voulu en
faire à cause que je partageais ceux qui
ont partagé les bons côtés mais parce
qu'ils adorent j'imagine justement de
ces bombes poursuivre un but de vous
lasser de passer de france et des choses
qui est apprend en faisant du sport
doute on apprend de la natation tout la
prévention ça reste après il ya du
positif qu'il reste à faire n'importe
quoi qui t'amène à vouloir améliorer
chaque sortie c'est sûr et il pourrait
faire l'on parle de ces disciplines
l'homme et idy des troubles qui sont
développés globalement tout il ya trop
longtemps y en a dans tous les sports de
haut niveau dans les pas d'un bon oeil
de l'excellent you il ya des choses
malsaines qui se passe rien dans ce qui
est retrouvé l'équilibré comme c'est ce
qui est le plus beau là dedans
après les compétitions de fait n'est
s'est malgré tout les avoir fait un
sport de haut niveau a été poussée se
retrouver de quoi qui est ce un pied tu
peux continuer un mode de vie y est
c'est les façons pas excessivement oui
bt juste vouloir être le meilleur dans
quoi que ce soit ça peut pas être
équilibré
cfoot faut que ce soit excessif une
impression si je suis pas mal certain
que ces deux modèles tout inspira mais
ces individus le la plupart j'imagine
samson sont heureux parce que justement
ils y accèdent à leur but mais y'a
pleins sphères de leur vie c'est certain
qu'ils sont carrément dysfonctionnelle
raison non plus s'ils se connaissaient
dépendez exacte tout le portrait de la
vie de ces gens là n'ont pas
nécessairement envie de changer de place
peut-être avec un autre
parce quelqu'un tu montre justement
juste le beau côté de tes victoires de
thé compétition décider ce qu'on voit
pas aussi tous les tous les sacrifices
puisse faire les sacrifices jeudi c'est
une bonne chose pour atteindre un but
mais en même temps j'ai envie de
sacrifier des relations avec ta famille
et qu'il va faire que peut-être pas
envie de sacrifier factice c'est un bal
en faucigny balança à ce projet
questionné ce qu'elles vivent leurs
avortements quand j'y repense à 17 ans
jeter a diet pour mes compétitions sur
ce cd bildt en développement étaient mes
amis et moi j'allais au gym le buteur
laissera aux pieds je fais et je manger
du poulet secte l'hébreu que lille était
sa maman des hospices grenier pied
j'avais un workshop un accomplissement
mais quand j'y repense c'est vraiment
spécial
ça fait partie du parcours puis je
serais sûrement pas la personne que je
suis aujourd'hui ch à toutes ces étapes
le exactement 4 oui merci vraiment
beaucoup de noirs mais samedi par balle
super bowl d'hubert belles et bonnes
conversations qu'on avait tout le monde
le monde ont vraiment aimé ce que c'est
super ça fait plaisir